[Applause]
wii sports the cultural phenomenon that
launched nintendo back to the top of the
food chain it managed to completely
transcend gaming culture and put
nintendo at the center of mainstream
media and we're like oh geez it's the
best selling console exclusive and the
fourth highest selling game of all time
wii sports is as vital to nintendo's
legacy and success as mario zelda even
pokemon
and yet it has been criminally absent
for almost an entire
decade with the exception of a haphazard
port to the wii u wii sports is nowhere
to be seen on nintendo's very successful
switch and it's all the more offensive
to watch its legacy slip to the sands of
time when all the pieces to give it life
maybe even capture a new generation are
all
right here
that
is a crime
i cannot stand
let's start at the beginning 15 years
ago an era where gaming culture and
marketing was fairly siloed among young
adults with ps2s and xbox 360s being the
dominating platforms to game on and
while i was absolutely one of those
young adults at the time i was actually
distracted with whatever nintendo had of
its sleeve next
spoiler alert
it's right there
nintendo had been trailing behind with a
series of less than successful consoles
under its belt like the gamecube n64 and
the virtual boy with most of the company
saving grace being the extremely popular
nintendo ds now while nintendo certainly
had a choke hold on the handheld market
they were struggling to keep a grasp on
the traditional console gamer the
hardcore gamer as some may put it a
market largely defined by big budgeted
action games with grimacing dudes
holding guns but nintendo was about to
flip the script and kick the pearly
gates to gaming completely open
enter
the wii
welcome to the next leap in gaming
nintendo skipped competing with the
hardcore gaming market and along with it
through the conventions of what was
understood as a controller out the
window with this thing package it up
with being motion controlled and it
becomes an extension of your own
movement like using a sword a gun or
to play sports and what to nail that
concept home harder than wii sports
suddenly this became your tennis racket
your baseball bat your golf club your
bowling ball and with this your boxing
gloves
the level entry to playing a video game
had suddenly become indisputably
approachable in ways it hadn't before
and so a pop cultural phenomenon had
erupted overnight wii sports felt like
it was everywhere conan played tennis
superstar serena williams at wii sports
we tennis attorneys took off in nyc and
melbourne
it bridged the gap into movie culture
when it was played at the 80th academy
awards with jon stewart oh hey all right
you go go good game mr john it was even
featured on daytime news because this
dude lost weight playing it every day
for six weeks nine pounds total two
percent body fat loss it was being used
for physical therapy and rehabilitation
or
rehabilitation rather the wii like its
code name was a revolution and that's
even despite everyone smashing their tvs
fast forward 15 years later
and it's nowhere to be
seen now maybe it's as simple as
acknowledging that it was just a trend
of its time i mean after all motion
controls have been adopted since then in
more nuanced ways maybe wii sports is
meant to live in a capsule of that era
and maybe i'm just looking at this whole
thing through rose tinted nostalgia
goggles
yearning for the days
of yesteryear
or am i
digging out wii sports today it is
unadulterated brazen fun even all this
time later on 15 year old tech
booting it up it is just sheer
simplicity there's no fluff no involved
exhaustive explanation it just rips
and with just five sports to choose from
the game needs no more or less to knock
it out
[Music]
[Applause]
tennis is still the pinnacle and most
addictive bowling is casual brilliance
at its finest gulf reaffirmed well i'll
never golf in real life
baseball reaffirmed that i was never
good
and boxing remains the height of wii
sports [ __ ] but there's no denying the
sick pleasure of beating a dude wearing
glasses with a smile on his face to a
bloody pulp
even when i was horrible at sports like
golf and baseball i was still having a
good time and its no-nonsense ranking
system was the ideal feedback loop to
encourage me to play just one more round
i am breaking a sincere sweat i feel
gross i feel like i need to take a
shower then there's the me's themselves
their limbs depiction rudimentary design
amplify the game's innocent nature it
makes flailing hysterically on a
windscreen or watching them fumble the
pick of a ball all the more a joy
[Applause]
truth be told playing this game today
this simple innocent
low commitment even considering all the
physical activity involved struck way
harder for me than i anticipated not
only did it reaffirm me wanting it on
switch it made me yearn for this
unabashed
clean slate charm that i think is
responsible for wii sports's
approachability and that isn't to say
that approachability doesn't exist in
other titles for the switch i think 51
classic games is an excellent example of
that and
one that actually utilizes motion
controls
for some of its games including bowling
it's a great bowling alternative to wii
sports bowling if that's something you
eagerly need in your life and
to play with your grandparents
or
someone else but even when looking at
the joy-con it's like a natural
progression of the wii remote it has all
the same functionalities as the weaver
mode does and even games that have been
brought over from the wii to the switch
today all utilize the exact same
functionality so just knowing that makes
it all the much more a crime
now naturally there are some games
trying to fill the wii sports gap like
instant sports uh which is an option to
say the least also nintendo has tried to
carry over wii sports with wii sports
club which was an hd remaster for the
wii u but its launch was rather the
antithesis of wii sports's simplicity
first it didn't have all the sports
available at launch additionally you'd
have to buy them individually for 10
or for two dollars you could rent them
for a day
yeah
so not only was wii sports club and
mishandling it was also a product of a
bygone wii u era and as it turns out
after the wii u nintendo has seemed to
have completely moved on from the wii
and me identity no nintendo lam me plaza
even street pass from the 3ds the me
brand association as a whole has taken a
back seat now if i'm being completely
honest it's fairly clear why wii sports
isn't on the switch first off
motion controls
aren't really a mainstream thing anymore
also i think nintendo made the right
move separating itself
after
the branding confusion of the wii u
these guys think they're better than us
what
oh it is time for wii u additionally
the switch
it ain't hurting to sell itself it
doesn't need a killer app to sell its
concept the concept sold itself i mean
as of this video the switch is sitting
at 89 million units sold which is bound
to surpass the wii's 101 million with
the oled switch model
but the thing that keeps rattling around
in my mind with this whole thing is that
wii sports is the single
most successful console exclusive ever
made that is 24 million units more than
super mario bros and 35 million units
more than pokemon red green and yellow
and while yes it did come packaged with
the wii it did not in japan and still
managed to be the best selling game for
the console
but really this isn't about recapturing
the success of wii sports but rather
acknowledging it with the same reverence
as mario zelda and pokemon in cementing
nintendo's impact on culture and the
industry as a whole we would like to
play the wii era certainly brought
nintendo back to his feet after some
missteps and it's hard to imagine that
success without the universal appeal of
a free sports game that came
pre-packaged with the console
so
you know it'd be like
cool and stuff to have wii sports
on the switch
like on the go
that'd be sweet just saying
just
15 love